whether you're debugging a specific
application or monitoring multiple
applications across several production
clusters
you need logs i'm here today to show you
how to use cloud logging to easily find
and analyze the logs you need from your
applications running on gke
this is the stackdoctor
[Music]
cloud logging is deeply integrated into
gke that means that collecting
infrastructure and application logs
is easy gke deploys a per node logging
agent then automatically collects
standard output and error logs
it then sends logs to the large router
which sends them to cloud logging and
any of the logging sync destinations
that you have configured
you can start viewing your logs as soon
as your application is deployed
the easiest place to find the logs is in
the logs viewer in the cloud console
you can get there by selecting that
option from the products menu
another way to access logs just for your
service quickly is from the gke workload
screen
just select your deployment and then
click container logs
either option brings you to the logs
viewer note that we're looking at the
log viewer preview
you may be more familiar with the
classic logs viewer which has less
functionality
the new logs viewer has four main areas
the query builder at the top
the histogram below that the logs field
explorer on the left
and the query results on the right the
query builder is at the top of the
screen
this is how you create and run queries
to retrieve the logs that you want
you can also add query parameters
directly and use the autocomplete to
select available fields
the logs fields explorer on the left is
there so you can easily find logs by the
field and value in the log payload
one example would be to look at all the
pods in the namespace
since i'm looking at logs for a specific
service already i can click on error in
the severity field to find just the
error logs for that service
let's do this now the histogram at the
top of the screen shows the frequency
and relative volume of the errors you're
seeing
you can also use the histogram to select
specific time ranges to search for
the query results show the actual log
entries that match our filters
you can expand any of the entries in the
results to see the full log payload i'm
seeing an authentication error in my
logs
finally you can click on any of the
payload fields and select show
matching entries to see all log entries
that contain this message if you want to
see where else you may be getting a
particular error
you've now learned how logs are ingested
from your gke workloads into cloud
logging
and how to use the logs viewer and its
field explorer and histogram features
to find exactly what you're looking for
i hope this helps you to debug and
troubleshoot your own workloads on gke
thanks for watching and come back soon
for more this is the snack doctor
stay healthy out there